well unfortunately it's looking like the
fourth of july federal holiday here in
the united states is an increasingly
dangerous day um it's sort of beyond the
scope of today's show to give you the
details of every mass shooting and
incident of gun violence that took place
over the fourth of july weekend hint
there were about 13 or 14 different mass
shootings over the weekend
uh but i want to talk about the reaction
the increasingly
i i mean it it's an absurd reaction that
exists in the united states to these
incidents again the focus from the
american right wing is on everything
other than the tools with which the
shootings themselves are carried out the
guns and it's now not only about doors
it's about ladders
it's about rooftops it's about alleys
unsecured alleys and i will explain it
all but in very rough strokes
another two
i mean listen there were multiple mass
shootings yesterday
the two that made the most headlines
include one in the swanky
chicago suburb of highland park which
took place during a fourth of july
parade where the shooter used a ladder
to get to a rooftop the shooter was
eventually captured by police and taken
into custody alive then there was
another incident where
as of this moment it appears that two
police officers at minimum were shot
during a fireworks event in philadelphia
pennsylvania and immediately we see the
focus go to things that don't really
make any sense in highland park well
well let's go backwards in uvalde texas
the problem was there were too many
doors at the school the doors were the
problem
and ted cruz and others saying
reduce the number of doors secure the
doors etc
in highland park illinois the shooter
used a ladder to get to a rooftop so the
problem is well we you can't just
re-leave random ladders around where
anybody could get to a rooftop too many
rooftops in the city that's a problem
unsecured rooftops and i put out a few
tweets about this
which many of you which seem to resonate
with many of you and they were sort of
in tongue-in-cheek the first one was
doors clearly are not a solution for
mass shootings like today's
so what is the next proposal from
republicans to avoid dealing with the
guns
and in the replies it's filled with
people saying well they're going to talk
about rooftops and ladders and all of
these things and they did
i then tweeted well ban rooftops
buildings should only have a bottom not
a top of course that's absurd
but these are the types of reactions
that we're seeing maybe ban parades
maybe we have to harden the parade
routes almost as if it's the you know
when there's a presidential inauguration
they harden
the route that the presidential
motorcade will take maybe every random
parade now needs that maybe ladders
should be registered no age limit to buy
a ladder but certainly we need a
national registry of everybody that bans
ladders
what of what i'm saying is a joke i
don't even know at this point i don't
even know because they want to deal with
everything
other than the firearms the police
commander
who is this this is the deputy chief
of lake county's sheriff department
christopher cavelli was asked
how did the shooter get to the roof well
it wasn't secured check this out
so the roof was a business and it looks
like uh access
to the roof via a ladder in an alley was
unsecure
right
a ladder that's attached to the building
guys there's all these ladders sometimes
they're fire escape ladders
they're all over the place they're
completely unsecured obviously because
people need those if there's a fire
they've got to get out well do we ban
the ladders or do we register the fire
escapes or do we lock them well but then
how do people escape well but then
there's elevators do
maybe the elevators need to be banned or
secured or well oh no but if the
elevator then there's the internal
staircases in the building we've got to
harden all ladders elevators staircases
and rooftops
well maybe that's not the solution maybe
instead
we just need bulletproof vests at all
parades because listen
they're gonna get up onto the roof they
might have a gun or they might have a uh
they might have a machete which they
could throw
from the rooftop so you've got to wear a
bulletproof vest when you go to a parade
that's the solution now
uh and unfortunately
some of them seem to now be accepting
that we're just gonna have these types
of events but it's okay because we're
gonna we need to have the guns j.r
majewski the trumpian u.s house
candidate who i interviewed he posted
yesterday i don't care if countries in
europe have less shoot by the way it
should be fewer shootings but that i'm
reading it as written i don't care if
countries in europe have less shootings
because they don't have guns i care
about the united states of america
and our second amendment rights i think
americans stopped caring what europe
thought of our country in
1776 he's straight up saying it is more
important
to have guns
than to not have mass shootings
ted cruz
immediately sending prayers ted and
heidi they sent prayers
and to that i asked on twitter
we've had another mass shooting
someone didn't pray hard enough
or correctly
or to the right deity who was it
guys
prayer that's how we stop this i'm
looking at you which one of you didn't
pray correctly or to the right god or on
the right day or enough times per month
one of you is responsible because you
did faulty prayer
come on guys we how do we win this when
half the country well
maybe not half
when a significant portion of the
country
including many of the moneyed interests
that influence gun policy are just
accepting we will send prayers but we
won't do anything about guns
okay we'd rather not have mass shootings
but if we have to have them in order to
keep our guns it's acceptable how can we
possibly deal with this issue when
that's the case one guy who is basically
ready to throw in the towel personally
and i sympathize with him is the mayor
of philadelphia and i want to talk about
that next
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below